[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis au volant d'une voiture au
milieu de la forêt je ne sais pas quel
chemin emprunter
né vers quelle destination me rendre la
route étroite et sinueuse les pneus de
ma voiture sont crevés je suis
littéralement perdu ça c'est exactement
le sentiment que j'ai eu quand je me
suis posé pour la première fois la
question comment vais-je faire pour
réussir dans la vie
j'ai 18 ans je viens d'avoir mon bac et
j'envisage mon avenir avec angoisse et
questionnement je ne sais pas ce que je
veux faire plus tard
enfin si ce que je veux c'est rendre
fiers mes parents et le reste de ma
famille mes amis et le reste mon
entourage m'ont cercle social en fait à
ce moment-là ce que je veux c'est de
sentir accepté par la société
alors pour savoir ce que celle ci nous
fait comme définition de ce qu'est la
réussite il faut revenir aux tous débuts
lors de notre naissance à la sortie du
ventre de notre mère des amis cryogénie
mais qu'il est beau ce petit alors en
fait plutôt qu'un nouveau-né beau mais
ça fait juste bien de le dire puis on
grandit on découvre notre première
chambre est les bleus si on a un garçon
elle est rose si on est une fille
les garçons jouent aux petites voitures
les filles jouent à la poupée à des
premiers repas des parents disent qu'il
faut manger des légumes particulièrement
des carottes parce que ça rend aimable
et c'est important d'être aimable en
société puis tu fais tes premiers pas à
l'école là on dit qu'il faut que tu
restes assis sur une chaise pendant des
heures à écouter le professeur n'étant
calme studieux et surtout sans bavarder
on dit aussi qu'il faut que tu sois bon
à l'école parce que plus tard ça te fera
gagner de l'argent et l'argent
contribuera grandement à ton bonheur
dans la société
julien dos laissant tu apprends que ce
n'est pas une petite graine que papa a
mise dans le ventre de maman pour que de
jeunesse et bien ce que tu as tenté de
faire toute la soirée avec amis et lors
de la première vous les mains en tentant
de passer à ton bac tu dois avoir une
idée précise de la personne que tu veux
devenir plus tard il est dimanche
toute la famille est réunie autour de la
table grands parents frères et soeurs
parents près
d'ailleurs ce soir et on perd ces
renforts le point sur la table te pose
la question suivante aux cas tu vas
bientôt passer ton bac
qu'est ce que tu veux faire plus tard
comment tu le vois dans dix ans une
goutte de sueur m'effleure légèrement la
joue heureusement j'ai appris par coeur
le refrain de ce que la société m'a si
bien renseigné
alors moi papa maman comment je me vois
dans dix ans je me vois avec un métier
qui me plaît où je viens surtout
beaucoup d'argent j'aurai une belle
maison je serai mariée une belle femme
dans une grosse voiture on mettre au
monde deux beaux enfants un garçon et
une fille et on s'aimera fidèlement
jusqu'à ce que la mort ne sais pas en
fait parce que la société à travers
notre cercle social nous inculque c'est
pour réussir il faut être le prototype
de l'homme avec un grand h
parfait alors j'ai peut-être de vous
décevoir ce soir vous tous qui êtes là
mais moi personnellement je suis tout
mais alors tout sauf l'homme parfait non
moi quand je suis sorti du ventre de ma
mère j'étais pas très bon on aurait dit
un peu de pâte atrassi puis moi je veux
pas aux petites voitures moi je faisais
des colliers en perles avec des perles
en bois toutes les couleurs moins viril
mais tout aussi amusants puis moi j'ai
jamais été très légumes
j'aimais pas les carottes donc peu
aimables et surtout surtout l'école et
moi on n'a jamais été copains on va dire
que j'ai jamais aimé ça elle me vendait
bien maintenant vous avez compris tu
très imparfait mais ce soir je n'ai plus
loin vous tous qui me regardent et est
beaucoup plus proche de moi que de la
perfection désolé de vous dire ça c'est
la vérité
vous avez bien pourquoi et bien et ça
vous l'avez sûrement déjà entendu durant
votre vie c'est monsieur et loïc shining
désolé pour l'accent anglais qu'il dit
beaucoup mieux que moi
chaque être humain est censé avoir une
personnalité unique être ce qu'aucun
autre ne peut être exactement et faire
ce qu'aucun autre ne peuvent faire
exactement
on le sait on bénéficie tous deux
qualités défauts différents qui font de
nous des êtres singuliers et en soit
c'est en ça que l'être humain est beau
c'est dans nos différences
maintenant qu'on sait en réalité ce que
la société à travers notre cercle social
nous inculque comme défini
mon propre de ce qu'est la réussite eh
ben on a vu que c'était totalement faux
donc je les ai donc à partir de là je me
suis dit comme c'est faux quelle
est-elle vraiment la réussite
comment dans dix ans dans une semaine
demain je peux me dire pas mal on est
sur un mondial c'est pas grave on
continue comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
se dire comment est ce que je peux me
dire la hausse car tu es sur la bonne
voie naturelle sicoval atteint entre 1 t
c'était sûrement début continue eh bien
je me suis posé un petit peu plus sur ce
mot réussite et j'ai cherché sa racine
étymologique
j'ai trouvé en latin excès aux dons pour
les deux personnes de la salle qui ont
fait de vote 1 pour une fois ça servira
à quelque chose ça veut dire se dépasser
ou sortir des limites
en fait ce prix serait peut-être là le
tout se serait d'arriver à prendre du
recul sur qui on est vraiment qu'est ce
qui vous fait vibrer qu'est ce qui nous
donne envie
le matin de se décoller l'oreille de
l'oreiller pour les un comble pour aller
accomplir ses rêves les plus fous et
faire quelque chose qui fait qu'en le
faisant on a l'impression d'être une
meilleure personne que la veille pour
vous illustrer ce point vous apporter un
objet qui ne tient tout particulièrement
à coeur qui représente le sport que je
fais depuis petit il doit être par là
bas je sais pas où les personnes peuvent
l'apporter
c'est un ballon de rugby
eh ben on lui passe le bonjour c'est un
ballon de rugby et il représente le
sport que je pratique depuis tout petit
l'impression qu'on se transmet de père
en fils dans ma famille et quand on
était quand tu étais petit avec mon père
on se mettait à côté de la maison on se
faisait comme ça des petites passes au
pied
il y avait d'un côté ma maison de
l'autre côté les voisins merci il arrive
à point nommé
si donc il y avait d'un côté comme je le
disais ma maison et de l'autre côté les
voisins n'ont qu'à compétences on se
faisait des petites passes au pied et
vous l'aurez compris pour éviter de
perdre le ballon il fallait le gérer sa
frappe
en bon gamin turbulent que j'étais au
bout de deux trois frappes je mettais un
grand coup de tartines de dans le ballon
par s'envole et se penche sur le toit de
la maison
à ce moment là le ballon devient mon
objectif et j'ai plusieurs chemins pour
y arriver le produit je pourrais passer
par l'intérieur de la maison
passé par les escaliers enfin atteint
mon objectif le deuxième je pourrais
prendre un hélicoptère des sens
beaucoup moins probable mais pas
impossible et puis le chemin le plus sûr
celui que la plupart empruntent frère
c'est l'échelle je l'apprends gelin
clinique contre le mieux et puis je n'ai
plus qu'à monter maintenant la question
que je me suis posée c'est la réussite
est-ce que c'est l'atteinte de
l'objectif ou est ce que c'est le chemin
qui mène alors naturellement on pourrait
se dire bah c'est l'atteinte de
l'objectif c'est le titre c'est le fait
d'avoir une promotion de soulever un
trophée est en soi pourquoi pas
évidemment tout cela nous procure un
sentiment de fierté un sentiment
d'accomplissement
mais pour combien de temps dix quinze
minutes à peu près le temps de savourer
une bonne vieille conférence tedx avec
tous les attributs pour connaît en
réalité tout cela n'est qu'un titre ce
serait comme une vulgaire couche de
mascara désolé mesdames qu'on mettrait
sur un visage beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus expérimentée avec du vécu avec des
choses à dire et ce visage dans mon
exemple assez léché
c'est le chemin qui mène à la teinte de
mon objectif c'est ce qui fait que tous
les matins je me lève comme je vous dis
précédemment pour faire quelque chose
qui me plaît et que chaque échelon de
cette échelle représente un petit
objectif vers mon rêve ultime
et même si au milieu de cette échelle je
me rends compte que j'atteindrai pas mon
rêve parce que c'est la vérité sinon ce
serait trop simple
on ne peut pas atteindre ces aides est
bien ce moment là serge suis déçu mais
au milieu de mon échelle je me retourne
et je regarde tous les échelons que j'ai
gravier de quelle manière j'ai trimé
depuis des semaines des mois des années
pour arriver là où je suis je me rends
compte que je suis au que je suis loin
que je suis une meilleure personne que
la veille et surtout que cette personne
que j'idolâtre est être et je m'en suis
énormément rapprochez vous l'aurez
compris la réussite n'est pas l'atteinte
de l'objectif ultime
mais c'est bien le chemin qui nous y
mène j'aimerais vous partager une
expérience que j'ai eu la chance de
vivre avec mon entreprise dernièrement
durant un séminaire un conférencier
connue à l'international michael aguilar
est montée sur scène pour nous apprendre
comment devenir des vendeurs d'élite jeu
dans le commerce et donc ils demandent à
une dame de monter sur scène avec en sa
possession un billet de 10 euros alors
que lui n'a qu'un simple gobelet la dame
monte sur scène et lui dit madame tout
d'abord enchanté vous avez un billet de
10 euros je vais vous levant compte ce
gobelet est ce que vous voulez
elle se dit je vais donner 10 euros pour
rien là tout son nom verbal est négatif
et lui dit clairement non à ce moment là
michel aguilar revient vers elle et lui
dit madame je vous assure
prenez ce gobelet vous ne le regretterez
jamais et même pire vous allez me
remercier après à ce moment là à travers
toute l'énergie qu'il dégage
et puis un petit peu de pression de la
foule aussi on va pas se mentir la dame
lui cède le guide il prend le gobelet
miguel aguilar prend le billet fait
quelques pas pour lui indiquer c'est par
là la sortie la dame un petit peu
sceptique descend les quelques marches
et des coûts en fait qu'il ya sur ce
gobelet un capuchon l autre le capuchon
le capuchon et découvre qu'il y avait en
fait à l'intérieur de ce gobelet un
billet de 20 euros
la conclusion que fait michael aguilar
sur ce court passage et qu'on n'est
jamais un aussi bon vendeur ja partir du
moment où on est persuadé que ce qu'on a
à offrir à notre client vaut beaucoup
plus que ce qu'il ou elle à nous offrir
en retour
eh bien vous tous qui me regardait ce
soir sachez que vous êtes les gobelets
nous sommes les gobelets mais je me mets
dedans et les 20 euros qui lie à
l'intérieur c'est notre volonté et vous
aujourd'hui à travers les différents
objectifs on peut se fixer dans la vie
on peut se dire j'ai un talent là dedans
parce que ça me plaît mais pierre ahmed
ou six styles elle en a puisque moi et
on aurait raison oui aujourd'hui on
pourrait se dire j'ai beaucoup de
qualités mais beaucoup de défauts aussi
dans ce domaine et ma marge de
progression est énorme et on aurait
raison mais aujourd'hui c'est du plus
profond de vous même vous êtes persuadé
qu'il peut y avoir n'importe qui qui se
mettent en travers de votre passage que
vous voulez plus que lui avec cette
[ __ ] volonté vous serez capable de
déplacer des montagnes
si je suis là ce soir j'ai pas fait le
tour du monde
j'ai pas écrit deux livres suis pas
entrepreneur je suis qu'un simple
étudiant et je la préfère passer un
message d'espoir et de motivation
principalement des jeunes qui comme moi
il ya quelques années
envisager leur avenir avec angoisse et
questionnements et pas seulement
justement je vois que on est beaucoup ce
soir c'est cool et il n'y a pas que des
jeunes pas on va dire la carapace il ya
aussi des jeunes qui ont plus d'années
de vécu je crois qu'on a tous un enfant
à l'intérieur de nous qu'on ait vingt
trente ou soixante dix ans qui a des
rêves et je crois que aujourd'hui je
rencontre même quelquefois
personnes qui peuvent avoir 40 50 ans et
qui ont tout pour être heureux à leur
place n'importe quelle personne aimerait
être comme avoir monté une boîte qui
cartonne avoir des enfants
une belle femme et c'est tout ce que
j'ai dit auparavant et qui à la fin
quand il se regarde dans le miroir se
disent je suis pas vraiment heureux quoi
et bien c'est aussi à ces personnes là
que je parle ce soir et je vous dis que
vous soyez grand ou petit que vous soyez
maigre gros vous soyez noir ou blanc gay
ou hétéro juif ou musulman valide ou
handicapé vous soyez intelligents ou
même traite répond il ya un talent qui
sommeille en vous qui vous est propre
qui ne demandent qu'une seule chose
c'est d'être révélée pour ça il faut
réussir à prendre de la hauteur en
mettant cet entonnoir sur toute cette
société vraiment savoir ce qu'on veut
pour arriver à faire tout ça ça demande
une ouverture d'esprit et d'ouverture
d'esprit est le fait de se dépasser de
sortir des limites
c'est la définition d'excès haut et
c'est ça aussi la réussite je terminerai
par cette phrase oscar wilde qui
m'inspire beaucoup
non pas seulement parce qu'il s'appelle
comme moi mais parce qu'en plus la
phrase est belle il disait l'homme peut
croire en l'impossible mais il ne pourra
jamais croire jamais en improbable
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]